all right all right John
no where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
uh La Canada
suburb of L.A tell me about your family
uh really good
family until you know till the divorce
but we're still all really close
um
uh yeah we were just I mean I I thought
it was a normal family until you know my
parents got a divorce and then
started having two separate families and
uh
then my mom moved us to Park City
Utah
and uh that was pretty cool
she wanted to be
live in a snow Town wanted to get away
from my dad
you know so I
I think that was that was a cool thing
in my life going moving to Perth City
is uh they give you a pass a ski pass
when you uh
when you're in school there so every
weekend it would be you know out on the
slopes and
that was fun I mean I enjoyed it I mean
any rough spots in your childhood
definitely some rough spots
um
I was abused when I was younger by uh
a friend of the family
who's also a police officer
how yeah what kind of reviews
sexual oh really yeah he was a he was a
cop yeah he's uh he worked at the
rampart station
and I I don't know if it was so much
that I mean
the abuse that was bad but it was the
exposure of the abuse that really
changed my life you know like it was
just My Little Secret
before but then
after like
my parents took me to counseling or
whatever they knew something was wrong
and so they brought it out of me and I
eventually told the counselor what was
going on and then that turned into you
know him getting into trouble and all
that stuff and
I just that led to like a lot of
thoughts and weird stuff with me like
because you know I'm like am I gay am I
not gay what's going on
um
and did my parents think that or I mean
what do they think and so like the
exposure of it was a lot
more damaging to me than the actual
abuse you know did you ever get caught
yeah he got caught he got fired he uh he
moved out of LA and I think
last I heard he was in um
North Carolina or something but he
actually okay so I moved to Utah and he
actually came out to Utah and
paid me like some money to uh
to uh what's it called when they
write a statement that says it didn't
happen and of course I was a young
I was I had a family then I had you know
a two-year-old son and I was trying to
survive so I I did it but I don't think
anything ever happened with it but
um yeah that's he tried to uh save it
all but I we never went to court or
anything but he did get fired he got
fired and um
yeah I think he's a real estate agent or
something now
you know but it is is kind of messed up
how he did it you know he's
it was it wasn't like all at once you
know it's just
like we were just wrestling around or
something one one day and then he just
grabbing my you know stuff and
and then uh it just went from there and
then for a long time I was like am I gay
am I gay I don't know is it bad so
right now I just have problems with that
in my life like reflection on who's
I actually am
like
sexually I guess
I'll find you in school
um I
went to uh
High School I dropped out
um in the junior junior year I dropped
out in the junior year
but when I I did get in trouble in Utah
and so I had to go to prison and I
finished my high school diploma there
and I also
became an electrician at that same time
through the program they have out there
in Utah
and that was actually a good thing for
me because I mean that being a
electrician is the best skill I've ever
had because
I can like go anywhere and work anywhere
and everyone's got electrical problems
and so
that's actually how I've been surviving
lately
you know you've been living on the
streets for how long
um it's been about 10 years I think and
uh
about minus two years I've been in SRO I
mean it's it's not living on the streets
so it'd be about eight years yeah what
drugs kind of took hold at what point in
your life
um
I'd say like after my son was born like
uh he was I was 19 when I had him
and her parents basically told me like
hey you gotta get a job and support your
daughter and your son and so I did it I
got a job I I was
digging stitches running sewer lines and
stuff
and uh
got an apartment and it held it down and
then we went through about three years
after that we went through a breakup and
um
that's when I really kind of started
falling into drugs and
and then I think five years after that I
wound up in prison
and so what was that for it was for the
manufacturing meth and fraud and
punches at a high speed chase and stuff
um I did three years out there and then
um
got out and I did
phenomenal it was 10 years before I got
in trouble again
so I was pretty happy with that and then
that that was like a hit and run that I
got
in trouble for and do you blame crystal
meth for
all the trouble you got into and the
situation you're in now absolutely
and if you go back a layer deeper would
you
stem that from the uh
the child abuse sexual abuse
I think so I think I I think I've had a
hard time dealing with it
and
I I don't know so much if it was
the sexual abuse or if it was the
exposure of the sexual abuse because
when the story came out yeah because
then it was like real like it was
and everybody knew and then
so I kind of didn't like that part but
it was just embarrassing yeah I I feel I
felt embarrassed yeah and plus I didn't
know like what
other people actually thought of me you
know and
I've had a hard time with that for a
while and
I don't know my son my son recently
passed away
because of fentanyl so I'm sorry yeah
it's been really
tough for me and
um
I don't know I just sucks
it sucks it
I couldn't show him like a better
path and like he just saw like what his
parents freaking is like
I don't know
what's your biggest fear now
that was my biggest fear
yeah it came true
my biggest fear now I don't know
um how old is your son he was 25.
and like I I totally blame his mom too
but I shouldn't it's it's it's me like I
don't know
but that's been really really really
tough this is this was like three months
ago and then he passed away
and
I just barely like got the ashes back
and stuff so it's been really tough he
was
living in Utah with his mom and uh
I just feel like I just feel like I
didn't do enough
to uh help a man this the the fentanyl
stuff's crazy like
I don't know I
I'm not I don't like it at all I mean it
just doesn't make sense to me like to do
a drug
where you could potentially die like
what's that's like just doing Poise and
then thinking you can get high off it
you know it's really pointless to me
but it's like big with the the younger
generation I don't get it
I don't know
what's your biggest regret in your life
um my biggest regret is
it's just it's not
is is being stubborn and not working it
out with my ex and staying sticking it
out and being a family
you know like it eventually led to me
being more of a drug addict and
her being more of a dry diet and my son
would be more I mean family is like so
important I think it's like it's just it
really is to me I think it's
and of course like what's messed up is
my dad's
kind of like started his own family you
know because he married got married
again and then they had kids she had
kids and then he moved away and was with
them and stuff and then I'd come over on
the weekends and stuff and that was
really hard to deal with too like seeing
like
him have like this whole other family
and then me put on the side burner and
stuff
um
so yeah my biggest figure right is that
definitely that and uh
been addicted to to math
crystal meth
how do you support yourself now
um
I do the gr and um like odd jobs and
stuff under you know I worked for like
the markets around here like fixing
Outlets or putting in security systems
or something you know get paid under the
table or whatever whatever but I
basically just
get out and use all that money to get
high with
have you tried to get clean
um no not recently I mean I had a seven
year period in my life where I was clean
and sober and I was I did phenomenal I
I got my driver's license back
I I got clean I me and my wife bought a
house
and
but the drugs just kept bringing me back
to the to the to meth I just can't get
over it like
because a guy like I told you before you
know I I remember being high when I was
younger because I was a hyperactive
child
and uh they had me on ridland all sorts
of stuff at 10 years old man I remember
being so high
that I I couldn't sleep and and I just
remember that same feel I have that same
feeling
remember on the medicine that I do when
I get high and so it feels like normal
to me you know I feel normal
psych meds
kind of open the door for
I do I think I think yeah I think it's
maybe
we shouldn't be doing that one like
I'm so the people are so young like
that's that's a lot
I don't know that's just I don't not
really qualified to talk about it but
I do feel like that
what would you say is the most important
lesson you
um
the most important lesson that I've
learned is to not be angry and to not
hold the grudge and and because
Life's too short to like be mad at
someone about something stupid like I
mean if you
love that person like don't be like
stubborn
I mean like I was with my my sons
I never got to say goodbye you know it's
really
tough for me
um he was
I had so many plans and stuff for us in
the future like
[Music]
tough stuff
I haven't really even talked about it
because it's it's I just I can't even
believe it I just can't believe it
but I can't believe it
all right Joe thank you so much for
sharing your story
I wish you lots of luck from here
thank you